j planète je bouffe cette caméra
je suis très serré c'est un 50 mm je me
suis acheté un gorillapod c'est sorte de
petit trépied flexible qu'on peut on
peut tordre dans tous les sens c'est
très pratique pour faire ce type de blog
en mode flemme de sortir le matériel
bonjour je voulais faire un petit blog
pour vous tenir au courant de tous j'en
suis parce que ça fait longtemps que je
n'ai point poster de vidéos sur cette
chaîne et pourtant je travaille
d'arrache-pied donc oui il s'est passé
beaucoup de choses va vous le savez
puisque j'avais parlé de la série time
warp pour laquelle j'ai lancé un nul et
le lui les temps atteint de tournage ont
commencé et pour ceux qui ont financé le
l'ul vous avez déjà vu la news comme
quoi on a commencé à tourner et le
week-end dernier et ça s'est très bien
passé
il nous reste trois jours de tournage
qui auront lieu en août
et tout ça fait que évidemment c'est
pour ça qu'il n'y a pas grand chose sur
la chaîne en ce moment parce que le
tournage ça prend du temps et les
préparatifs prennent du temps et puis
c'est la fin de l'année scolaire et du
coup il ya beaucoup de boulot
et voilà c'est compliqué la première
chose qui fait qu'il n'ya pas eu de
chroniques de profs début juin c'est les
préparatifs du nul puisque gens
racontent les préparatifs de time warp
la deuxième chose qui fait qu'il n'ya
pas eu de chroniques de profs ce mois ci
c'est que j'ai un sujet je vais arrêter
de jouer avec l élastique j'ai un sujet
qui me plaît beaucoup
pour lequel j'ai déjà fiché un petit
livre et il nous reste affiché un gros
livre un gros livre que vous voyez et si
on n'a pas ce pôle et le titre et du
coup j'en suis j'ai fichiers ça il ne
reste à afficher ça c'est beaucoup donc
à raison de 40 pages par jour je devrais
avoir fini à la fin de la semaine
si je fais quarante pages par jour et ce
qui me permettrait de filmer
la semaine prochaine et de le sortir
dans deux semaines
idéalement idéalement dans deux semaines
au pire des cas donc trois semaines il y
aura un chronique de profs qui sortira
et qui sera bien et après ça on passera
en rythme d'été donc peut-être quelques
petites vidéos mais pas de chronique de
prendre fin en septembre parce que c'est
les vacances et que les vacances seront
bien remplies parce que time warp
il y avait autre chose dont je voulais
vous parler oui dimanche prochain jeu
tourner une vidéo autres un court
métrage de science fiction que j'ai
écrit et dans lequel je joue très peu
parce qu'il faut que je filme forcément
bon genre avec un tout petit rôle mais
ça va être drôle ça va être bien
c'est ça se passe bien c'est la première
fois que je réalise vraiment puisque
pour taiwan j'ai une real beaucoup plus
doux et moi j'ai un autre projet de
court métrage
mais je n'ai pas encore mis en route
mais j'ai très envie de le faire et ça
sera aussi de la science fiction et ça
sera aussi drôle normalement et je suis
aussi invité au médiéval fantastique de
mormal normal qu'ils se trouvent dans le
nord de la france tu peux au sud-est de
valenciennes qui ont lieu les 14 et 15
juillet et je serai présente le 14
juillet bon apparemment ça commence le
vendredi soir mais dans tous les cas je
serai présente le samedi pour une
conférence comme on est dans une forêt
on restera dans le thème de la forêt et
je n'en sais pas plus et il y aura
d'autres conférenciers il y aura trois
autres conférenciers qu'on ait deux
samedi et de dimanche mais après ils ont
pas encore trop parler de cette partie
du programme donc je vais pas spoiler le
programme parce que ça ne se fait pas on
ne divulgue h pas ce genre d'information
dit vu le cacher c'est un amour par aman
bush conséquence du tournage de taiwan
et les fenêtres ouvertes tout le
week-end chez moi les mouches bon c'est
à peu près tout pour les nouvelles du
coup tu es noir qu'avance le court
métrage que je tends dimanche chronique
de profs qui avance aussi le festival 14
et 15 juillet je serai aussi présente à
montbazon d'ailleurs mais en touriste si
vous croisez vous pouvez dire bonjour
mais je suis là pour la même chose que
vous voir des belles conférences et
manger les fouilles bien et bien il ne
me reste plus qu'à vous souhaiter la
bonne soirée
c'était très naturel aller sinon j'ai
été invité au château du clos lucé aussi
enfin châteauroux son petit château au
clos lucé qui se trouve à amboise et
j'ai passé une super journée là bas que
j'ai raconté sur twitter
et peut-être que je ferai un jour une
vidéo sur le thème du colosse et
particulièrement des honneurs de vinci
puisque c'est lui qui a vécu là bas
c'est pour lui qu'on était là même si
lui il est plus là et c'est encore
obscures je sais pas quand parce que le
temps encore une fois mais en tout cas
le policier s'était ainsi été une très
bonne expérience donc si vous êtes dans
le coin je ne suis absolument pas
sponsorisé pour dire ça mais je vous
encourage à y aller c'était joli
bref des bisous au revoir et vivement
les vacances